más de 700.000 personas han huido de sus
pueblos en el norte de mozambique tras
los ataques de militantes vinculados con
el autodenominado grupo estado islámico
en los campos de refugiados donde ahora
viven la cotidianidad parece normal pero
las secuelas psicológicas de estos
ataques son profundas los equipos de
médicos sin fronteras ayudan a estas
víctimas a sobreponerse de sus dolencias
este hombre mayor perdió la movilidad de
su brazo tratando de escapar el de un
grupo armado en septiembre pasado mire a
la derecha y a la izquierda y
me dispararon pero logré escaparme
corrí lejos muy lejos no todos tuvieron
la misma suerte el esposo de esta mujer
fue asesinado su hija fue secuestrada
por unos yihadistas que ella llama 'la
chiva' ella estaba con su hermana los
llevaba se las llevaron una de ellas
logró escaparse pero mi hija de 20 años
no regresó le entregué su foto a la cruz
roja todavía no tengo noticias
en este campamento 17 madres perdieron a
sus hijas y cada vez que se habla sobre
eso se quiebran
según el observatorio del medio rural
una ong de mozambique que recoge los
testimonios de familias de refugiados al
menos 1000 millones de jóvenes mujeres
menores de 20 años han sido secuestradas
algunas han sido casadas a la fuerza con
militantes islámicos radicales otras son
enviadas a redes de prostitución fuera
de mozambique
el mes pasado las organizaciones
internacionales solo encontraron a ocho
ellas lloren para expresar sus emociones
cuando se sabe lo que han vivido es
necesario que lloren porque es lo que
sienten momento lo que sienten como
grupo es algo bueno encallados a cientos
de kilómetros de sus tierras estas
poblaciones de pescadores han tenido
muchas dificultades para reconstruirse
tras el ataque en palmas el pasado 23 de
marzo muchos desplazados viven ahora en
pemba la capital de la provincia de cabo
delgado situada a 250 kilómetros más al
sur la población de esta ciudad
portuaria se duplicó en un año pero cada
vez hay menos hombres de negocios muchas
empresas han evacuado a su personal
hacia la capital maputo el consuelo en
horario británico que trabaja aquí como
contador desde 2006 perdió el 30% de su
clientela desde los últimos ataques él
también se va a ir de pemba no importa
que no sea de mozambique o expatriado
todo el mundo tiene miedo hasta mis
empleados
se a corto plazo total no continúa sus
actividades pero habrá dinero en maputo
2 los responsables de la empresa
francesa totales se niegan a dar
declaraciones pero interrumpieron la
construcción de su fábrica de gas y
suspendieron todos los contratos con sus
prestatarios la mayor inversión privada
en áfrica está congelada hasta que la
situación de seguridad se solucione el
gobierno de mozambique acepta recibir
ayuda en el plano de la formación o del
equipamiento pero privilegia un apoyo
militar regional para este antiguo
secretario ejecutivo de la ssa de la
comunidad de desarrollo de áfrica
austral es necesario resolver primero la
cuestión de estos grupos armados entre
vecinos
esos hombres que vienen de tanzania de
la república democrática de congo de
somalia y de otros países pero también
de mozambique esos hombres tienen campos
de entrenamiento del otro lado de
nuestras fronteras y agua dónde me cansé
y vienen aquí para sus sospechosos
hay que hacer algo para tratar el
problema de fondo design
estás
son
santonja es tu vida warcraft en primer
lugar sería necesario volver a entrenar
y volver aquí para nuestros soldados
en otro clip
es muy difícil conocer los objetivos de
los grupos armados del norte de
mozambique muchos piensan que la
respuesta militar no será suficiente
para este analista el movimiento se
aprovecha de la pobreza y de las
frustraciones de la población
algunos señalan al grupo estado islámico
a los yihadistas
sin duda eso hace parte del problema de
las filas pero también hay que resaltar
las fallas del gobierno state
y se tiene la impresión de que el estado
se esfuerza más proteger los intereses
de las multinacionales petroleras y que
no hace mayor cosa por las formaciones
locales tienen font y insights of local
population el gobierno organizará
reuniones para dialogar con las
poblaciones musulmanas del norte del
país pero se necesitará más tiempo para
que los refugiados puedan regresar a sus
casas la provincia de cabo delgado
también se ha convertido en el corredor
del este africano de tráfico de heroína
interpol estima que más de 100 millones
de dólares de droga transitan todos los
años por estas costas militantes
islámicos y cómplices del crimen
organizado serán los últimos en querer
abandonar este pequeño rincón
paradisiaco